It's been difficult to identify quote, mood genes,
for traits like bipolar disorder for two main
reasons. The first is that bipolar disorder is
more of a collection of syndromes, rather than
a specific condition. There's no single diagnostic test
or biomarker that allows us to delineate the
trait. And heterogeneity in the trait itself, makes
it more difficult to identify coherent genetic correlations.
And the second reason is that bipolar disorder may be
caused by a very large number of genetic factors that
interact among themselves, and with the environment. And this means
that any given SNV that might explain part of the trait.
Would require a huge population to find it and that
same SNV would only account for a small amount of the
overall genetic risk. Until we have more precise information, patients
and families are going to have to deal with the best technology
that we have available. And we could all do
a better job at understanding how bipolar disorder develops.